Tim Burton brings his vision of a
dark Dreamland to the big screen in
a live-action remake of Dumbo, but what did
he change from the original movie and how
does it compare to the animated classic?
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and
today I'm explaining the top twelve biggest
differences between Disney's 1941 Dumbo movie
and the brand new live-action Dumbo film.
Plus, I'll be revealing some easter eggs
to the original movie you may have missed.
One of the biggest changes in the live-action
movie is that there are no talking animals.
That means that Dumbo's best friend Timothy Q
Mouse is no longer part of the story, though
we do get a nod to him as two of the movie's
new characters, Milly and Joe, have a little
mouse circus and not only is one of their
mice dressed like the animated rodent, but we
even see it eat a peanut, just like the first
time we met Timothy in the classic film.
Milly and Joe, in fact, take on Timothy's
role as Dumbo's confidant and champion; so
they stand up for Dumbo when he's mistreated,
comfort him when his mother's locked
up, and help him with his flying.
In keeping with the filmmakers' desire to
make the world feel as real as possible,
Dumbo's mother, Mrs Jumbo, is actually pregnant
with her baby in the live-action remake, meaning
there aren't any/are no baby-delivering storks,
though there is an easter egg to their animated
role as we see them in the new movie just before
we glimpse baby Dumbo for the very first time.
Like in the original, Mrs Jumbo protects her
young son from bullying and threats, which
once again lands her in elephant jail, though
on this occasion, the filmmakers up the stakes,
making the consequences for shielding her son even
more dire, though they also add a modern twist to
her eventual reunion with her little one.
There's no chorus of female elephants to
criticise and ridicule Dumbo this time,
but he does get more than enough of that
from some of the circus workers, crowd, and
even Danny DeVito's Ringmaster at first.
Talking storks, elephants, and mice aren't the
only creatures cut from the live-action film.
Also canned are the Crows who helped young Dumbo
fly, and their use of feathers and psychology
to encourage his aerial abilities
is taken over by Joe and Milly.
The Crows' absence from the new movie is hardly
surprising given they've been heavily criticised
as racist stereotypes of African Americans.
There is a little easter egg to their famous
song "When I See An Elephant Fly" though
when the Dreamland ringmaster introduces
Dumbo's act with a slight variation on
the following lines from the Crows:
"Well, I've seen a horsefly."
"Ah, I've seen a dragonfly."
"Yeah, I've seen a housefly."
Most of the live-action film's new
characters are human, but there is one
notable new animal addition: a monkey,
who just like the other animals never talks
and is completely computer generated.
The new CGI primate reminds me of the popular
real-life one that featured in the Night at the
Museum movies; and, like that capuchin monkey,
this new mischievous monkey's role is to add some
comic relief, which it does plenty of by popping
up in some surprising places and by performing
both Shakespeare and damsel-in-distress
routines as part of the circus and also by
popping up in some surprising places.
"Is that a monkey in your desk?"
"Just for emergencies."
Just like the star of the
animated movie, the computer-generated lead
of the live-action film is entirely adorable.
And despite the many tweaks to
the airborne elephant's story,
such as the origin of his name and how we find
out he can fly, Dumbo's character remains as
heart-warming and moving as before, which means
his adventures will likely break your heart
before finally putting it back together again.
And, the film's core messages of self-belief and
that difference is strength not weakness are
still very much there; indeed, they're further
highlighted by Dumbo's adopted human family.
The classic movie lasts a mere 64 minutes compared
to the new film's almost two-hour runtime, so it's
hardly surprising there's plenty of new material
in Tim Burton's reimagining of the tale.
In fact, the scene where Dumbo flies down from a
burning building at the end of the original film
is recreated about a third of the way into the
live-action movie and is really the jumping-off
point for a whole new strand to the flying
elephant's story, which is now set just after
the First World War rather than during the Second
World War when the animated film was made.
In another change, this time Dumbo doesn't
get drunk on champagne and
hallucinate pink elephants.
However, there is a gorgeous version of that
memorable moment as the circus performers make
bubble elephants that multiply and dance.
There's even a suggestion that the new
baby Dumbo gets mesmerised watching the
performance as he nods along to the music
with an entranced look upon his face.
When it comes to songs, Dumbo takes a leaf
out of Disney's live-action Cinderella rather
than their recent take on Beauty And The Beast,
with only one of the full songs from the
animation making it into the new film.
Actress Sharon Rooney, who plays a circus
mermaid, gives a sweet performance of "Baby
Mine", the beautiful lullaby that accompanies an
emotional scene between Dumbo and his mother.
And you should listen out for some nice easter
eggs to the animation's other famous songs,
including a nod to "Pink Elephants
on Parade" as well as Danny DeVito
singing a couple of lines from "Casey Jr".
Plus, during the credits, you'll hear different
versions of those songs again as well as a jazzy
instrumental of "When I See An Elephant Fly".
With the lack of talking animals,
the human characters in Burton's
movie become much more important.
Danny DeVito is great as the struggling
circus owner, Max Medici, who has a bigger role
in the new film than the original Ringmaster.
Initially, Medici wants to hide Dumbo's large
ears from the circus-going public, and although
he echoes some of the animated elephants' mean
words and locks up Mrs Jumbo, he turns out to be
a more obviously sympathetic character than
his animated counterpart, as he tries to do
the best he can for his large circus family of
strongmen, mermaids, snake charmers, and more.
The addition of Michael Keaton's V.A. Vandevere is
a major change from the original animation, where
although the chorus of elephants are incredibly
nasty to Dumbo and the tormenting boys are also
horribly cruel, there's no one stand-out villain.
In contrast, Keaton's ruthless entrepreneur who's
desperate to buy Dumbo's circus so he
can exploit the miraculous pachyderm
and make a mountain of money adds a new
and interesting plot to this version.
It also takes us to Dreamland, a theme park that
Vandevere sees as the future of entertainment,
but which has a much darker side.
Something else the filmmakers wanted
to achieve with the human characters
was that Dumbo's story would be a way
for them to reflect on their own situations.
So, for example, former circus star and wounded
war veteran Holt Farrier's relationship with his
children parallels the relationship between Dumbo
and Mrs Jumbo because, just as young Dumbo is
trying to reconnect with his mum, so too Holt and
his children are trying to put their family back
together after being forced apart by the war.
Milly and Joe also know how it feels to
have lost a mother which adds an extra
dimension to the bond they form with Dumbo.
Although the human characters are a neat way for
the filmmakers to differentiate this version
of Dumbo from the original, they're an area
where the new movie can fall a little flat.
Even though they get more screentime than
their animated counterparts like Timothy Q Mouse,
generally they just don't make the same impact.
The issue isn't the cast list, which is suitably
impressive including Colin Farrell, Eva Green,
and Alan Arkin; the thing is that there are
almost too many new human characters to the
point that they're pretty thinly drawn.
Still, this is Dumbo's story and there's
still a lot of sweetness, tears, and joy to be
found in this beautifully designed world.
Now it's your turn to let me know
which is your favourite Dumbo movie.
Tap in the top right and, after you've cast
your vote, you'll be able to see the results.
If you enjoy deep-dives, theories and
behind-the-scenes secrets about your
favourite Disney movies, be sure to subscribe
and hit the bell to get all my new videos.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!